um
yeah what up council my name is chad
kroger
i'm an activist and tanning connoisseur
um i'm here to speak on a huge issue
yeah so basically my buddies and i went
out to palm springs to raja and airbnb
um it's actually sylvester stallone's
old crib
it's got a pool and a tennis court
it's really tight
um i'm definitely going to give our host
trish 5 out of 5 stars
anyways
after about nine dak worries i pass out
on the tennis court for about six hours
and i woke up like this
totally disfigured
this
is not a normal sunburn council
as you can see
i am massively torched
and i realize
the earth is too hot now
so that's why we are here to propose a
solution to climate change